rudy giuliani america's mayor
one of the really great mayors in the
history of our country greatest mayor in
the history of new york
just got raided by the feds the feds
busted into his office
and department this according to the
washington post
the investigation into giuliani revolves
around his interactions with ukrainian
figures ahead of last year's
presidential election
as he sought information that might
prove politically damaging to
then-candidate joe biden
and pressed for the ouster of the u.s
ambassador to ukraine
cnn added he hasn't been charged
and has denied wrongdoing but but
america's mayor gets his office and
department busted into
because he was apparently digging up
dirt
on joe biden on behalf of donald trump
oh that's what it is that's what this is
a political persecution
got it you'll notice that prominent
democrats didn't get their offices
busted into
for digging up dirt in russia on donald
trump and they didn't even really dig up
dirt
they just hired this intelligence guy
they hired a bunch of spooks one of whom
was christopher steele
to create a totally uncorroborated
read fictional dossier on what donald
trump did in russia
we know that the democrats did what they
are accusing
rudy giuliani of doing on behalf of
donald trump
we know that happened but they don't
face consequences and giuliani
apparently does he is at least facing
intimidation he's at least facing the
threat
because the american political regime
is gay oriented to support
the left and to attack the right
and to only apply certain laws on the
right and not on the left and to
criminalize
things that the life gets away with when
the right doesn't hey hold on if by some
strange
chance we are still on youtube right now
i need you to ring the button
and smash the doodad and hit the gizmo i
don't know man i don't know what you you
say
subscribe to this channel so that you do
not miss a single video
because i'll tell you the powers that be
they don't always love our content okay
so just make sure you subscribe right
now ring that bell
and that way you will get to see all of
these pearls of wisdom
coming up
[Music]
you